Born in Paterson, New Jersey in 1910 to Gustav
and Otillia Haast, Bill Haast was interested
in snakes since he was 7 years old.
This interest turned into something of an
obsession during summer trips to Boy Scout
camp, beginning when he was 11.
The next year Bill suffered his first snake
bite from a timber rattlesnake he tried to
catch.
At the time, Bill was four miles from the
camp’s first aid station, so he applied
the standard field dressing of the day (making
crossed cuts over the fang marks and applying
potassium permanganate) and walked back to
camp.
Although his arm had swollen pretty well before
getting back to camp, he ultimately recovered
with no long term ill effects.
When he returned to camp the following year,
he suffered another bite from yet another
snake he was trying to catch, this time a
large copperhead.
Having learned his lesson from the previous
year, he was equipped with a snakebite kit
and was immediately injected with anti-venom.
Despite the early treatment, he was hospitalized
for a week after this bite.
young-billNot satisfied with snakes in the
wild, Bill began collecting them via mail
order catalogs as well.
When he brought his first one home, he later
stated his terrified mother refused to be
near it and fled the apartment for three days,
initially refusing to come back until he got
rid of the snakes.
Soon, however, she agreed he could keep, and
even grow, his little collection of snakes.
Restless and confident, Bill spent his final
year in high school sneaking out of the building
the second his mom was out of sight after
dropping him off.
He’d then simply wander around all day.
By age 16 in the late 1920s, he gave up the
ruse and joined a roadside snake show, hoping
to make his way to Florida after reading in
a catalog that the diamondback rattle snake
he purchased was shipped out of Florida.
After the traveling snake show shut down due
to the effects of the Great Depression, he
eventually did indeed make his way to the
Florida Everglades, where he supported himself
by rooming with and helping a bootlegger.
While this gave him ample time and opportunity
to catch and study various snakes, ultimately
the bootlegging entrepreneur was arrested.
At this point, Bill had a dream- to start
a snake farm.
Unfortunately for him, that required money.
So he decided to go back to school where he
studied to become an airplane mechanic.
Upon graduation, he was hired by Pan Am as
a flight engineer and traveled the world,
allowing him to collect even more exotic snakes.
He generally brought his snakes back via safely
storing them away in his toolbox.
He stated of this, “In those days there
were no laws prohibiting it, but the crew
members didn’t appreciate it.”
Besides collecting often deadly snakes from
around the world and bringing them on planes
back home, Bill also spent his time as a flight
engineer saving up money to build a large
snake farm.
By 1946, he was able to purchase a plot of
land in south Miami, sold his house, and began
building his Serpentarium.
Unfortunately for him, his wife, Ann, didn’t
exactly appreciate his obsession with snakes
nor the new direction her husband was taking
with his life, and she soon divorced him.
Undeterred, one year later Bill opened the
Serpentarium with a skeleton staff of himself,
his new wife, Clarita, who was much more supportive
of his little snake enterprise, and his son,
Bill Jr., who, after being bitten four times
by the snakes, left the snake farm to seek
safer work.
milking-snake2Over the next 20 years, Bill
amassed an impressive array of venomous snakes
from around the world, at any given time having
in excess of 500 snakes on his little farm.
You might think such an endeavor wouldn’t
be very profitable, but Bill found ways to
make quite a bit of money off his snake farm.
He generated income in two ways.
First, he “milked” venom from his 60 species
of snakes in front of a paying audience every
day.
This not only generated revenue from ticket
sales, but also from the sale of the raw material
needed to produce anti-venom- a gram of which
would net as much as $5,000 in some cases,
taking 100 or so milkings to produce one gram.
Being something of a dangerous profession
with accidental bites not uncommon, Bill also
decided to try to use the mithridatism approach
to protecting himself against the snakes-
namely, injecting himself with gradually increasing
doses of venom from different snakes he milked
regularly, including the Cape, King and Indian
cobras.
injecting-snake-venomThis worked.
In the 1950s, although he was bitten by cobras
approximately 20 times, he had few ill-effects
and didn’t need any anti-venom.
Eventually, his immunity to many snake bites
had grown so strong that he often donated
blood to treat snakebite victims when anti-venom
for a particular type of venom was not otherwise
available.
According to the New York Times, over 20 people
who likely would have died without the antibodies
in his blood were saved because of his donations,
including in one instance where Bill flew
all the way to Venezuela to donate a pint
of his blood to be used for a boy who’d
been bitten.
For this act, the Venezuelan government made
Bill an honorary citizen of the country.
(Normally snake anti-venom is made via injecting
diluted venom into certain mammals and then
collecting the resulting antibodies from the
animal’s blood.)
charming-snakeWhile the farm was very profitable
for Bill, a non-snake-related tragedy led
to the closing of the Serpentarium.
You see, in addition to snakes, Bill also
kept alligators and crocodiles in a pit on
the premises.
In the late 1970s, a six-year-old boy fell
into the pit.
Seeing a tasty snack, one of the crocodiles
lunged for the boy before a random bystander,
Nicolas Caulineau and the boy’s father,
could get to him.
The two men did eventually manage to get on
top of the near one ton crocodile and attempted
to free the boy, but it was too late.
While today Bill would have been sued into
oblivion for this, the boy’s parents did
not blame Bill for the accident.
Nevertheless, he never forgave himself and
not long after closed the snake farm… but
not before firing nine rounds from his Luger
pistol into the crocodile in question, ultimately
resulting in it dying about an hour after
being shot.
Years earlier, Bill developed a keen interest
in the medicinal uses of snake venom when
he and a University of Miami researcher experimented
with its utility in treating polio, with encouraging
results, before Dr. Jonas Salk came up with
an effective and safe vaccine against the
disease.
Now without his snake farm to run, Bill decided
to devote his time to once again exploring
various snake venoms’ medicinal properties
with medical professionals.
This culminated in Bill and a Miami doctor
treating over 6,000 patients suffering from
multiple sclerosis and arthritis with a certain
blend of snake venom.
While some of their research and results were
promising, in 1980, the FDA shut the pair
down, claiming that Bill’s manufacturing
process on the venom used for injections was
not rigorous enough.
Undeterred, in 1990 Bill persisted with his
research at the Miami Serpentarium Laboratories
he established.
Bill also continued to inject himself with
a variety of venoms, which ultimately came
from 32 different snake species.
Although he had long thought that his daily
venom regimen contributed to his good health,
a sample size of one certainly isn’t good
enough to give definitive credit to anything.
When he reached 100 years old, he was asked
about this, stating, “Aging is hard.
Sometimes, you feel useless.
But I always felt I would live this long.
It was intuitive.
I always told people I’d live past 100,
and I still feel I will.
Is it the venom?
I don’t know.”
Bill Haast died of natural causes some six
months after turning 100, on June 15, 2011.
In his lifetime, he stated he had been bitten
by snakes approximately 173 times, 20 of which
were nearly fatal.
Among the more notable of these strikes, he
had a rather nasty incident with an eastern
diamondback rattlesnake that left one of his
hands looking a bit like a claw.
In another significant strike, a Malayan pit
viper managed to cause significant damage
to his index finger.
In yet another instance, a cottonmouth snake
sank its fangs into one of his fingers, resulting
in the finger turning black almost instantly.
Concerned, he called his wife over and had
her lop off the blackened bit of his fingertip
with garden clippers before the venom could
spread.
In an incident in 1989, a particularly nasty
strike from a Pakistani pit viper nearly killed
him, but according to The Associated Press,
someone in the White House managed to use
one of their contacts in Iran to get rare
vials of the anti-venom from that country
to Bill, who ultimately recovered.
Despite his love for snakes, he did note that
they don’t make the best pets, “You could
have a snake for 30 years and the second you
leave his cage door cracked, he’s gone.
And they’ll never come to you unless you’re
holding a mouse in your teeth.”
When asked about his thoughts on life, having
lived to over 100, he stated, “The art of
living is not an instinct; it must be learned.
Isn’t it a pity that it takes all of it
before we know how to use that which we no
longer have?”